it's an epic clash in California the
president visiting the liberal
stronghold and having major
disagreements with its leaders on
hot-button issues the president setting
off liberal activists after raising
millions in the state protestors fought
with Trump's supporters outside one of
the fundraisers in Beverly Hills
this comes after Hollywood celebrities
threatened to out his donors but that's
not all the president continuing to
attack cities there and the homeless
crisis saying quote we can't let Los
Angeles San Francisco and numerous other
cities destroy themselves by allowing
what's happening there are policemen on
the beat who are getting sick they're
actually sick they're going to the
hospital we can't let that happen and
earlier today Trump killing california's
ability to set its own auto emission
standards Emily you're from California
let me begin with you Auto emission
standards I would think that most
conservatives would say that's a states
rights issue well I think part of his
argument which I firmly support is the
fact that without the regulations
there'll be higher innovation and the
ability now for the market to set prices
rather than the state to do it in kind
of this manufactured way if I can speak
for a second to on his disagreements
quote-unquote with those liberal leaders
he's exactly right and there was a
letter that the that governor Newsom
sent to trump on behalf of most of the
mayors and he they essentially said look
homelessness is a decade's old problem
and they asked for more handouts they
asked for 50,000 additional vouchers and
to increase the value of the vouchers
but if I were citizens still of
California I would be saying where is my
six hundred million dollars in taxpayer
money going that I gave you last year
where's the additional six billion
dollars that was just budgeted from my
tax dollars where is that going now
so they're arguing with a president and
saying that he doesn't believe in
actually fixing homelessness but nothing
they are doing is helping even though
they are spending more and more dollars
of taxpayers to attack the problem that
literally is making people sick and will
potentially start an epidemic in that
state anytime soon okay let's let's
stick with a fuel emissions for a second
and we'll go to
because there's so much you know black
and Trump in California go right ahead
well I just because this has been going
on for a long time California as you
might remember you're a little older
than Emily but am i okay California's 53
what the surgery can do California had
long had air quality issues okay so they
were given that special permission to
deal with their air quality issues
meaning pollution dirty and remember you
member have brown it used to be in Los
Angeles this what President Trump is
talking about is greenhouse gases and
it's about climate change it's a
separate thing that President Obama put
forward but climate change does not just
affect California right that is like a
carbon goes one molecule goes all the
way around the world in seven days so
what there would be week yeah wow that's
an amazing fact the Trump administration
is basically saying to California you're
not going to be able to dictate the rest
of the world well the rest of the
countries emissions when it comes to
safety and miles per gallon just because
of climate change that is more of a
universal thing and taking it back so I
think it got a little bit out of whack
it's not just about air quality air
quality you can still do those types of
things on terms of the pollution in the
dirt and everything others other cities
have done that California shouldn't have
special dispensation on climate change
well so Jesse what you see though is
that it's 66 percent of Americans oppose
the president keep freezing the fuel
efficiency standards in the state of
California 67 percent of Californians
support their own standards and the oh
and the car companies are saying we were
willing to go along with California
because we see you know the advent of
electric cars and other innovative ways
of getting cars to move the car
companies want a uniform standard and he
hasn't cut the emissions standard he
just stopped it from growing to a
radical height that actually can kill
people because if you think about it if
you make it like 58 55 miles a gallon or
whatever you're creating these very very
light costly cars you get into an
accident with a car like that there's
more people that die so all he's saying
that the cars are gonna be safer because
they're gonna be stronger and they're
just going to be a little more
for regular middle-class Americans and I
think that's fine in terms of the
homelessness situation California wants
to be its own Republic they ignore
federal immigration law federal marriage
law federal drug laws they always
ignoring the federal law then all of a
sudden they have a big homeless crisis
and they say hey feds can we have some
of your money to help fix this they
should have all the money in the world
they have the highest taxes a huge tax
base they're the most compassionate and
Democrats control every single level of
government so why aren't they doing
anything about it
Scott Adams retweeted a very nice
article the other day and it says why
California keeps making homelessness
worse a number of reasons the
liberalized drug laws they have no
mandatory treatment if someone's running
around like crazy a lunatic they can't
help those people and they screwed up
their housing other warm-weather states
like Arizona red state has less tax
revenue they don't have this problem
because they have strong oversight the
law enforcement they coordinate with
them and they don't let just like drug
addict crazy people roam the streets and
keep coming in and out of prison so if
you look at the way they've mismanaged
this think about how they've mismanaged
the high-speed rail remember the train
that was supposed to go from San
Francisco to Los Angeles it was supposed
to take ten years it was supposed to
cost thirty three billion dollars you're
gonna do it under three hours now they
have a cost overrun of forty four
billion dollars thirteen years in
addition to the ten years it's going to
take it now it's gonna cost it's gonna
take over three hours to get to and fro
kind of camp they barely managed to lay
down any track either so if they can't
even do something like that
no wonder they can't fix the homeless
problem how can you cite Scott Adams for
the retweet and not give credit to the
guy who wrote the article because I
can't pronounce his name
so Gregg let's start with homelessness
and all right I think when I hear this I
think to myself I think President Trump
likes this fight because he likes to go
after big cities and he likes to go
after Democrats who run big cities right
and so it strikes me as like grievance
or resentment politics against
democratic run or
liberal big6 because he's not doing this
in Kentucky or West Virginia or high
where you have opioid des they all of
the opiate think whether or not I
actually agree with some of the things
he's doing what so what so what if this
is a political stunt I mean I mean
seriously so what if a political stunt
results in saving the lives of a lot of
people getting people off the street
getting people into treatment I say
let's have more political stunts I'm for
political stunts if they actually solve
problems but what's interesting to me is
how do you get such neglect to be
acceptable for so long because you live
in a huge state where the rich never
have to see the poor I mean this is the
ultimate inequality unit rich never have
to go downtown they never take the
subway I don't know anybody who takes
the subway in LA the governor being
governor of California is such a cush
job because the rich people who support
you they don't have to care about the
taxes cuz they can afford it they don't
have to care about the homeless because
they never see them they don't have to
care about the disease that's being
spread because they'll never set foot in
Skid Row so that's what Newsom doesn't
have any pressure because they don't
care if you subtract politics and the
media who are basically driving this
divisive business model you could solve
these problems and you could accept that
Trump would but you can't accept Trump
to solve the problem because your ego
won't let it he could solve this we all
know we want to get drug addicts off the
street we want to get the mental
mentally ill into institutions and we
want to get the people who are truly
down on their luck the help that they
need but as long as Trump does it the
left can't let that I think the only
solution I've heard though is there's a
federal office building that's vacant
and he's gonna make that available but I
mean that's not speaking to the issues
you just raised no I think that they
haven't presented all that they would do
that that was a possibility like that
was like something that was floated I
think it's even if it's a political
stunt I think it's politically smart for
Republicans to campaign in California
because you remember one of the things
that the Democrats constantly say and
they're right he lost the pot for the
vote but if he can increase his margins
just a little bit in California is a
place where you do still have pockets of
conservatives you do have a it's just
such a big state you're not going to win
the
I'm not gonna say that the Republican
can win California in 2020 but can you
increase the number of people that vote
from you so that's what this is about I
would make a penny also he's just
raising a ton of money for his campaign
the money quick point on that because we
did a whole homeless segment package for
the five down in LA I did with dr. drew
and it's a multi-faceted issue what's so
disturbing about governor Newsom of
California coming out and saying it's
only about affordable housing is first
of all he's ignoring his past when he
was mayor of San Francisco Kara not cash
did not work there is still a homeless
problem there that is increasing by the
year and by continuing to focus on just
one aspect of it they're ignoring
everything else that this president is
at least touching on regardless of the
intent but as a California and everyone
should care exactly who's addressing
who's not bado just stood in Skid Row
and was screaming for federal dollars
just two days ago or whatever ignoring
the fact that this state is addressing
billions to it that isn't helping the
problem before we end up homeless we
better have some heads